[Music]
let's talk season 15 of the boys it's a
little over a month away and if you
think the brotherly love between Adam
Levine and Blake Shelton to fit in a
cooling period well you don't know Adam
Lake and I have this great relationship
where you can't all I'll go really hard
it up you're borderline sociopath here
yeah they're so big Blake that when you
clap it's like two pieces of meat
slapping together I'm gonna be a
commercial break or we'll cut and I'll
walk over to this chair until I came out
is that over the lines and he's like
he's like say bring it I don't care and
now you know the secret behind our
favorite bromance but did you know this
the maroon 5 frontman is turning
shirtless model et has the exclusive
first look at Adam's new campaign for
the fragrance wide by Yves Saint Laurent
and he's got some pretty strong words
for his buddy Blake well now we know
that you smell really good I want to
know what Blake smells like yeah big hey
where is his own special scent Oklahoma
stank the accents would be like body
odor farm work hunting lameness we know
he tends to copy you because you were
sexiest man alive then he was sexiest
man alive so now that you have a
fragrance everything he can do I can do
better
oh I love it that Blake looking at the
behind-the-scenes making-of the
commercial is just a reminder of why we
love us some Adam Aziz his favorite shot
driving down the iconic Le River no
childhood saw Terminator 2 like doesn't
want to drive a fast car through the LA
River because once you saw it or knew
you had to there was two iconic films
actually done there do you know the
other one was the other one dad
Greece Lebanon was it Greece was it
really well
I shouldn't have thunk for you actually
that was probably a bad joke that was
that was not bad you know you could
judge me right now I could never bear
data I would never judge you
you're nice and the boys that's good I'm
nice on the voice oh he seems to be nice
all the time come on Adam Adam is also
on tour with his band Maroon five
they're enjoying some downtime from
their red dil Blues tour but are back on
stage on August the 25th and Mexico
you